[Music]  Kourtney Kardashian is feeling salty  disgusting and sisters Kim and khloé  aren't having it why are you so these  days in a new promo clip for season 15  of Keeping Up with the Kardashians we  see the famous siblings butting heads I  don't understand I'm so afraid of her  I'm like so afraid of her  Kim and Khloe sit down with a pretty  disinterested Kourtney who spends most  of the conversation yawning and on her  phone she's like no don't we needed to  sit here and stare Kourtney finally  chimes in with a diss who let you choose  black covers for your furniture  disgusting who shoes is black that's  nice Kourtney well thanks for coming  over and thanks for being so lovely  Khloe hits back and asks the question on  everyone's mind what is up your ass  seriously what is wrong with you  [Music]